I'm now going to transition into what
happens we're just like last topic you
have a look at not just the algebra the
numbers but can you draw me a picture
you have a look at some graphs so here
is it example let's have a look at this
this graph shows just like we had a look
at in last topic a linear relationship
here between have a look at the axes
carefully between the time the amount of
time that you've put your body into a
load for instance and then on the
vertical axis you can see there's the
amount of interest okay so these two
quantities are related you could
probably guess the time most people
would say that's the independent
variable you could change that and the
amount of interest it responds it's the
dependent variable okay so now that I've
got those two let's have a look at
what's being asked of us and see if we
can use the graph to interpret what's
going on the graph shows the interest
owed where two thousand dollars is
invested at four point five percent
simple interest use the graph to find ok
so I'm going to look carefully at what's
being asked of me and that i'm going to
go over to the graph and see if i could
interpret it properly the amount of
interest earned after six years ok so
i'm looking for the horizontal axis if
that's the year the time axis and when
you have a look at this guy my ruler
here if you go across to 16 years which
you can see just over here on the right
hand side to work out the amount of
interest all i need to do is as i have
before measure up from that six spot
like so and you can see where it
intersects with the line graph now i
want to read across there to the
vertical axis so again get a grab my
ruler and it looks like it very very
neatly goes straight for the graph on to
that spot which looks to be if you zoom
being really carefully or if you know
you look really closely at your piece of
paper there I looks to be five boxes
between 500 and 600 so if there are five
boxes that go 100 that means that each
one should be 20 and I'll just check is
that one's going to be 5 20 that's a bit
thick let's try that again they get a
little bit easier to read this one if it
was 520 that would make this 5 45 65 80
and yes the next one will be 600 so I
got the scale
that's a good sign so now I look at that
they say we'll look that line it clearly
goes off to 540 so my answer to part 1
hour part a rather is that the amount of
interest is going to be i equals 540 and
no calculation is required I've read
that off the graph and like we've
demonstrated before if your graph is
accurate that this one is then that's
the whole point of it you don't have to
do calculations you just look at the
picture okay it exactly the same way I'm
going to look at Part B it says the time
taken to earn $350 interest okay 350
let's do a bit a little bit closer
that's going to be exactly halfway
between 300 and 400 which unfortunately
for us is not exactly on one of these
gridlines but I can still measure and do
it pretty accurately i think between 300
and 400 halfway I think I've got to get
a line about there that looks like where
it's going and you can see now that's
from the interests access and now i'm
going to measure all the way down to the
tiebacks itself got my vertical line
here if I draw it down and try be as
accurate as I cared the horizontal axis
because it's measuring something
completely different to the vertical
axis it has a completely different scale
it's not surprising I still do though
have five boxes between each one of the
numbers and so that looks to be like I'm
going to have point2 for each square now
we're going to just try to check that to
confirm if I had the first 13.2 then
this one will be 3.4 this one will be
3.6 this one would be 3.8 and yes the
next one would be four if I keep on
going up so now having a look it seems
to be that the light I've drawn down
this this light here it's halfway
between the three point eight and four
which looks to be like it's going to be
three point nine so Part B the time
taken to that about it interest which
I've read off from here that's where 350
would be that's going to be n equals
three point nine years and I've done ok
so again this is really nice if you get
a graph you actually at the graph is
good you minimize the number of
calculations you have to do which is a
real plus